thomas murphy
go off king hi it's me thomas and today
is brandon lee's birthday and she's a
grandma like me
i'm a grandpa too if you hear that
friendly
but just you know brinley i'm it's your
birthday and your grandma
76 years old and i've seen that before
in downtown atlanta
the tower crane i think it's used for
building stuff
the tower crane
and also yes all the events yes
everything was cancelled this year
i am definitely yes ready to say goodbye
to 2020.
you will not be missed and
plus i always end that part of the song
like towards the end
and i hope we don't have another drought
because i heard this song i'm dreaming
of a wet
and freezing january
and she's a nice person berno lee
respect the classics yes
better than the modern tara swift ones
always
and uh oh yeah what else am i gonna say
oh yeah
the airport is huge in atlanta it's big
it's a big airport
delta is the hub i believe yes all the
empty chairs that cnn gets all its
ratings too which is pretty cool
hartsfield jackson and also there's a
thing called peachtree
in atlanta georgia and the headquarters
is yes coca-cola
that is where the headquarters thank you
for shaking my hand and giving me the
tart attention i crave up nah it was
nice meeting you man
the headquarters two in atlanta yes ted
turner
and also uh one oh yeah our told you you
have to wear a face covering
but it's your only yes i know
what was that noise and today is my
anniversary too
yes and the whole month of february
2020 the rainstorm no it didn't happen
it didn't happen it's he's right it was
a dry february it was a dry february and
he knew about the deaths
of hugh downs he was almost a hundred
regis philemon 89.
kurt douglas he was 104
and sean connery 90. oh yeah
2021 will be a lot better
you got to get the dioxin first brenda
come on
thomas don't get the vaccine
i have a feeling that vaccines probably
haven't helped you in the past
maybe i'm wrong and
uh oh yeah
i guess about it so i guess i'm going to
i gotta go so bye
bye great meeting you this weekend king
great meeting you too kringas bingas i
don't
know which one of you what your real
name was but it was nice
i'm sure it was one of you and it was
nice meeting you
hi it's me thomas and also on today is
man ambiolic's birthday from
the tv show the big bang theory as amy
she's 45 years old
and i subscribed to your channel man
bialik i did
thomas don't and
it's also bob barker's birthday from the
tv show the price is right
he is 97 years old and yeah he's he's a
grandpa is he a grandpa
is he do you think guys let's take our
bets right now go to mybookie.com
uh i haven't seen this full video yet so
i'm not cheating either um
is he going to mention the bob barker's
or grandpa
what do you think
he only likes american-made stuff so it
has to be
made in the usa he doesn't want
imports no that's what he wants
he only wants american-made stuff made
in the usa
so he wants the same is yes monty hall
let's make a deal who also died yes
he was 97 years old and maybe yeah psych
i wasn't there
get pranked squab oh [ __ ] you got me
that's a total good prank bro it's time
for him to go at the age of 97.
it's time for him to go
and uh oh yeah what i had for my
anniversary dinner on brendale's
birthday
is popeyes very good
it's very good
and also oh yeah
there will be football on tomorrow and
uh yeah
so is there anything else i want to say
oh yeah
the 18th of friday which is like
actually no i don't think i can because
i get
watch macgyver but maybe like the 19th
i'll watch
a christmas story
yes but just you know like with the
restaurant that they went to like which
is chinese they didn't space out the
tables no
thomas you're gonna you're not gonna do
anything about barker right
just out of curiosity
no they didn't do that
they did inside but not like to go
like what we have now yes
which is literally nothing
and um is there anything else i want to
say i guess about it so i guess i'm
going so i gotta go so
bye bye bye thomas
this is the one i was very excited to
play so
you know what i won't even set it up
hi it's me thomas and today is here
sword's birthday and [ __ ] you
you piece of [ __ ] is there any radio
stations that will not buy her music
it is taylor swift's birthday and i
don't like her is there any other radio
stations in the bay area that will not
play her music please let me know mm-hmm
because nobody likes tarantula's music
she's a horrible singer she ruined my
halloween 2020.
she did that's why i did the hand
sanitizer in the microwave
it blew the door open but the microwave
still works
and also oh yeah
taylor swift
is preventing our boy thomas murphy
from buying lottery tickets
the fact that this [ __ ] in your [ __ ]
taylor swift because you're doing it on
purpose
the fact is this [ __ ] can't keep her
[ __ ] voice off the airwaves
so thomas thomas murphy could have a
little bit of luck this christmas
really pisses me off
it really pisses me off how
[ __ ] dare you
oh i'm mad thomas kenny
is not keeping thomas home because he's
not afraid of
that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
she's doing it on purpose i she is doing
it on purpose
i [ __ ] saw thomas at work last week
royce
i go to that store to work like three
days of for the week
thomas we say hi here and we love them
this [ __ ]
taylor swift oh
oh i i am oh i am really mad all right
thomas sorry i mean
i didn't go keep going off thomas what
the [ __ ] thomas
coming in hot
may i ask a favor again you guys are
great at this if one of you wants to
help me please
especially after hearing that little
part
can somebody make me
a thomas murphy is all elite aew package
please
an aw video i would really appreciate it
i would love it thomas murphy is aw
elite
please please with the music and all
that please can you
out of this video with the thomas murphy
with the taylor swift stuff you could
cut out the fluff just make it you know
really
good you know thing i would really
appreciate it
but jesus christ thomas coming in with
the fire
if she wears a swimsuit of course yes in
2027
water won't conquered they will not play
tara swift
they will not and i think this thing
will be all over oh
speaking of that i hope taylor swift
gets the eyes
but in 2027 this will be all over with
no more masks if you're hearing this
i'm going to keep going on and on and on
about this
and uh oh yeah
the one favorite christmas song i like
is rob thomas's new york christmas
that's the better one i always get my
work done when i hear it yes i do
do we have to add that to the christmas
songs rob thomas's new york christmas
we'll check it out i don't remember that
song
it's gonna be really busy closer to
christmas
it will be so i'm gonna go so
remember do not buy terraces music
i'm going to go now so bye bye
i'm bringing up to the main show
obviously not today because mercer is
being gay
but whenever whenever uh whenever
princess merch decides he wants to do a
show
uh probably tomorrow uh we'll definitely
cover that i'm here i i'm i'm i'm
working
all right i'm here showing up
that's why they call me royce show up
lopez